an early morning prayer vigil for Aretha
Franklin drew dozens of people to her
Detroit church this morning parishioners
and community members have been visiting
the new Bethel Baptist Church to offer
their prayers for the legendary singer
who is said to be under hospice care at
her home Lattimore duty of our streaming
network cbsn is inside the church glad
good morning good morning it was right
here in this church where a young Aretha
Franklin found her soul through the
power of gospel music she began singing
for the congregation here when she was
just a teenager and I just want to give
you a sense of how important this church
is to her and how important she is to
the church follow along with me here
into what they call the history room of
New Bethel Baptist Church and you can
see just along these walls there are
photographs line that show the history
of this church and the history of Aretha
Franklin's association with it this is
her father the Reverend C of Franklin
you can see pictures of her here with
her sister and her father there are
historical pictures here there is the
Reverend CL Franklin with Coretta Scott
King the widow of dr. Martin Luther King
and right above that you can see photos
of Aretha Franklin performing right here
at this church now I had an opportunity
to speak to the current pastor of the
church Robert Smith jr. take a listen to
what he had to say how important has
Aretha been to New Bethel well call it a
lifeblood the lifeblood the lifeblood
without it I don't think we would be in
existence today because her name has
kept us in the public's eye
pastor tells us that Aretha has returned
to the church over and over to perform
to host events one annual event she
hosts lasts three days and includes
musical performers and meals for the
church community and get this we just
had an opportunity to speak to miss
Franklin's secretary coordinator she
tells us she spoke to miss Franklin as
she's known in the neighborhood where
she grew up she spoke to her yesterday
she's alert
she's eating she's doing well she's
actually even watching television
coverage of all the well-wishes and all
the prayers that are pouring in from
around the world
and there have been in person visits as
well as well the legendary singer icon
native of Michigan Stevie Wonder he
stopped by to say hello to her as well
yesterday be honest well it's good to
hear that she's doing well and the Lord
and watching and hopefully not in too
much pain to lifeblood of that church
and for her to know how how much she is
loved to know that so many people are
pulling for her and sending her all the
best there's a lot of love and endless
love for a riether Franklin out there